really shown him up wouldn't it i'
brought in some burritos or some colored
greens or some pad tie love pad tie it's
CID greens what it's CID
greens it doesn't really make sense CU
you don't call them collared people
that's
offensive okay well it's after 5
so thank you very much
buav Vista hoscar thank you good job oh
my
man thank you
Brazil
nice hey
hey we can
go that's
fine
uh not a bad
day finally I want to thank
God because God gave me this
dundy and I feel God in this Chili's
tonight ladies and gentlemen oh
[Laughter]
yeah so I guess I'll see you
in 10 hours what are you going to do
with your time off travel yeah I've been
looking forward to
it it's going to
be really nice going to find
myself you have new music
yeah
definitely oh wow that is really
interesting what your love I'm just
kidding I can't see anything look
closer oh okay one point for me tied up
oh you're dead what what are you going
to do bring it Beasley bring it oh yeah
the move ooh not such an ultimate
fighter now huh hey put me down put me
down oh my God hey put me down
hey it's getting kind of Rowdy down
there yeah
D sometimes I just don't get
Roy I mean I don't know
so what's it like dating a
cheerleader
no
I'm
cold FL I'll just shut
it hey Pam what's
up yeah no tell them I will give him
General specifics tomorrow okay yes say
hi to Pam hi Pam hi Pam yes that is Josh
and Dwight and Jim Pam says hi have fun
on your date very good talk to you later
[Music]
bye D Mifflin uh hey oh my God
hi hi sorry I forgot Kevin's extension
it's a fantasy football thing oh and I
was I was just going to go through the
system CU I didn't think you'd be
there why why are you still there I had
to work
late Jan's making me keep a log of
everything Michael does all
day
wow you think you could send me a copy
of that yeah
totally
so so do you oh I'm sorry go ahead uh no
I um everything's pretty much the same
here oh good a little
different what time is it
there what time is it
here um we're in the same time zone oh
yeah right how far away did you think we
were I don't know felt
far yeah
how are your feet medium rare
thanks the real reason that I went to
Stamford was because I wanted to
be not
here I
know and even though I came back
I just feel like I've never
really come
back well I wish you
would
truce yeah I guess since I won you did
win you did
win anyway I'm going to need three
copies of each of these stable and
Coen I'm totally
kidding I'm going to need
four that's weird I mean that's weird to
have sex in the office and that's where
you work right
mhm you you're in a meeting and nobody
knows that you've had sex there except
for you and
him
e
ah oh hey hey hey no time to chat well
we were just looking for Ryan so he's
not here hey you're looking for me oh
yeah we were we were just looking to say
hi so
hey no you weren't no we weren't you
wanted to have sex in my office NOP
definitely not that's disgusting it's
it's it's cool just um try to put
everything back where you found it uh
text me when you're finished I'll be out
here hey you don't have
to that was so embarrassing I'm going to
die that was really
rough let me make something clear Jim
and I have never and will never have sex
in the office no because the office
isn't what I'd consider a romantic
place besides we have something those
other people don't have which is a home
and a bed and a
shower
what
no no we took a walk we took a
walk about 10 minutes
ago no I didn't know what to
say yes I
know um I don't know Mom he's my best
friend yeah he's
great yeah I think I
am um I have to go I
will listen
Jim
you have no idea how long I wanted to do
that me
too I think we're just
drunk no I'm not
drunk are you
drunk no
Jim you really going to marry
him
okay